bonjour jean paul chang bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france ce matin après tout c'est
toutes ces tractations diplomatiques on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé de la chine qui
pourtant dans ce dans cette crise
ukrainienne soutient la russie
va parler d'un soutien total disons
qu'il ya là aussi bénéficie d'un capital
de sympathie plus important à pékin
pékin a été surtout impliqué dans les
jeux olympiques donc il sait pendant
quinze jours séjour hésité très contents
de leur succès dans le cas des
organisateurs donc ils n'ont pas suivi
vraiment le teint tôt des médias
occidentaux sur ce qui se passe il en
ukraine n'ont pas dit tous les jours que
la russie avait envoyé lire ukraine ceci
dit ils ont été ils ont ils ont ils
n'ont pas été surpris par ce qui se
passe et des analystes chinois et d'une
façon générale les observateurs sont un
peu unanimes sur le fait que ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est la conséquence
de la longue longue et lente expansion
de l'otan
dans la direction de des frontières
russes là dessus en tout cas c'est une
maïs qui fait l'unanimité avec pendant
que derrière les listes des affaires
étrangères effectivement alors
on le voit dans les médias et aussi dans
des sous la plume des analystes chinois
des spécialistes de ces questions là il
pense que c'est effectivement la
géopolitique la pression de de
l'expansion d'une alliance militaire ils
le comprennent comme ça d'autant plus
facilement que il me semble à même le
même type de pression lorsque les
amériques a essayé de monter de plus en
plus d'alliance au tour de la chine et
pour contenir la chine comme le web ou
le hocus avec l'australie l'angleterre
le japon l'inde et s'est donc ils ont
l'impression que tout ce qui est
effectivement alliance militaire qui se
renforce vis-à-vis d'un tiers force un
jour c'est hier à prendre les mesures
pour sa sécurité donc là dessus il ya un
point commun donc mais ceci dit il faut
rappeler quand même que la chine
apprécie aussi les très bonnes relations
et que l'ukraine et que par ailleurs la
chine défend évidemment
le principe de la souveraineté
d'intégrité territoriale pour chacun des
pays elle respecte ne le respectent de
la charte des nations unies d'ailleurs
sur ce point là il ya la question de
taiwan est ce que pour vous on peut
faire le parallèle entre ce qui se passe
en ukraine et l'attitude des etats-unis
envers taïwan
la chine est très très très clairs là
dessus
quand même fait partie de la chine
jordan a dit que taiwan était était
indépendant qui me semble en novembre
dernier n'a jamais osé dire que dans nos
idoles c'est la ligne rouge dont il ya
une ambiguïté toujours l'indépendance
éventuellement elles vont également
proclamé par les indépendantistes de
taiwan seule ligne rouge que la chine ne
tolérerait pas de débat donc dans la
chine de leurs épaules des passants
par contre c'est des autorités de taiwan
qui ont tout à fait intérêt à
s'accrocher à ses prises pour montrer
que ils sont dans la même position
victimaire éventuellement que que
l'ukraine visait la russie ce qui est
évidemment ce qui provoque évidemment
les irritations pékin mais non les
parisiens ceci dit les des
doigts binh dinh craque quand même
effectivement chez les dirigeants
chinois que les occidentaux
un jour s'occupe d'appel reconnaît
taïwan comme comme la russie a reconnu
joxé la phrase de joe by dane qui est
acquis alors c'est vrai que les médias
ont dit qu il semblait parler de taïwan
il est indépendant il prend ses propres
décisions on sait que les etats-unis
aussi fournissent des armes à taïwan
alors qu'ils ont signé
justement le taiwan relations act qui
qui dit que la chine et est une et
indivisible
oui tout à fait donc c'est la
contradiction et l'ambiguïté de la
position américaine qui arrangeait tout
le monde qui arrangeait tout le monde
depuis l'établissement des relations
sino américaines avec le voyage de nixon
il ya cinquante ans exactement en ce
moment donc
là dessus les chinois les observe
effectivement il s'inquiète de ce que
les américains éventuellement sorte ce
qui n'est pas le cas parce
qu'aujourd'hui 10 américain se rapproche
un peu de pékin aussi parce qu'il
cherche pas à voir également deux
ennemis géopolitique de cette période-là
en même temps ce qui fait que monsieur
blinken a téléphoné ans ou à oignies
hier ou avant-hier pour effectivement
demandé la pression chinoise et essayent
d'obtenir quand même le soutien de la
chine le cas échéant au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu ce qui fait
effectivement sourire un peu les chinois
je blinken a commencé par féliciter les
chinois pour le succès des jeux
olympiques quand on se rappelle des
récents boycott diplomatique les
avancées de la chine mais aujourd'hui on
va les chercher de sandales a besoin
mais l'émissaire chinois à l'onu
avant-hier avait appelé toutes les
parties à la retenue est ce que est ce
qu'il ya eu des commentaires en chine
sur sur les sanctions prises et les
déclarations de joe bannière alors cette
position qui savent plus en plus
affirmée c'est-à-dire de un peu abstract
abstrait points qui consiste à dire
bonne volonté les négociations la paix
avant tout notre n'en rajoutez pas
chacun chacun est appelé à la retenue
sas a toujours la pression chinoise ceci
dit derrière effectivement il ça que ils
seront appelés à soutenir la russie sur
le plan technique de la finance et des
échanges économiques
si jamais les sanctions deviennent très
importants notamment pour le système de
paiement
international de règlement etc il ya des
lignes de soin très important entre le
rouble et le génie gbits/s qui permet
déjà au commerce
bilatéral russo chinois de connaître un
niveau jamais atteint a donc ça n'arrête
pas de monter
la wii s'ils peuvent vendre des
quantités additionnelles
supplémentaire de glace naturelle de la
chine qui en a besoin donc là dessus sur
le plan économique comme ils sont très
complémentaire il est clair que les
sanctions les gosses nous rapprocher
davantage merci beaucoup jean-paul
chambre pour toutes ces précisions dans
la matinale d'ayrté france